you know I watched this film last night
and I have a 15 year old daughter and
this was not easy for me to take in and
it was frightening and it was a lot of
me trying to figure out what I need to
do next as a mother
um why did you want to be part of this
story why did you want to tell the story
knowing these events some of these true
are true to Jessica yeah I think because
they were true to Jessica yeah I I think
that oftentimes we have a sense of well
it's not happening to me then it's not
happening anywhere else
and I do think that that thin veil has
since vanished in our society and I
think that now whether it comes from gun
violence or sexual assault everything
now feels like it's in our backyard and
I do want people to talk about it and I
do want people to acknowledge that it's
happening and I don't want people to
think that just because it's not
happening in their backyard it's not
happening in mine
um and I think that that's really
important I also thought that the
character was incredibly fun to play if
you take those two incidents away that
yet yes those two very big incidents
mold our character's future and put on a
trajectory of who she ultimately becomes
yeah the Journey of who she becomes what
is what to me was most relatable
do you think she's Fierce your character
the fact that she's come out of it and
she's stronger and better and she almost
feels freed from it all yeah of course
you go back to the last line in the film
I think that that completely embodies
who it is that we always wanted her to
be so much of the inner dialogue that
plays out in the movie you wish that she
would just say out loud yeah just wish
that she would actually say those words
out loud to the person she's looking at
or to herself and it's not till the very
end where she actually says that to the
woman and I always looked at that line
as in 20 Pages prior to that she would
have had the internal dialogue said that
word internally and then outwardly would
have said something really different and
to me it was the first moment where she
actually the two versions of herself
come together
what was that initial conversation with
Jessica
about the character yeah or wait we
talked about well it's so interesting
that you asked that I don't know if Jess
and I ever had a conversation about
Jessica
ah we only ever talked about it as far
as it pertains to Tiffany or Ani there
was a day on the set where a jet no
there are a couple days in the set the
Jess that Jessica didn't want to be on
the set for obvious reasons for for
things that happened on set she didn't
want to look at uh
other than that
it never actually talked about
her we only ever talked about the
character that's really interesting uh
another Netflix show that you're working
on is then that that 90s show uh Kelso
and Jackie are back my my childhood is
back I mean who had more fun on set you
or Ashton okay okay all right let's let
me tell you about 90 show it's fantastic
and the kids in it are great
waiting for a very short period of time
very very quickly to introduce
a character okay but here's my and
Bonnie Turner's back and Terry Turner
and it's unbelievable that they were
able to get her original it's so cool
and the sets are just because it takes
place in Deborah Jones and kurtwood's
house a kitty in their house and Eric's
old house and in the basement
um
it was super surreal to be on set but
what was more surreal was they gave me a
15 year old I was like I don't have a
Facebook
excuse you so that was a harsh pill to
swallow because as I was like it's
impossible for me to have a 15 year old
my husband turns and goes no it's not I
was like you'll be quiet so uh that was
a really interesting uh you know time
got put in perspective real quick uh but
it's really fun and I hope that people
it's like a beautiful love letter to 70s
Mila it's incredible that you guys met
on That 70s Show and here and you are
married with kids I mean you just never
I know you're gonna find love you never
know where anything happens you gotta
keep an open mind keep an open heart and
just stay positive we talk about it all
the time and there's people that have
come out of the woodwork that's like oh
we always knew these two would end up
together both no you eat it there's no
way we have this weird story that that
is just so wild like yeah there's yeah
so you just you never know uh well I
knew you guys were going to end up
together yeah okay
okay
you were absolutely amazing
congratulations on the film and I can't
wait for every woman to watch this film
so thank you thank you so much